[Music]
how do other languages accommodate
non-binary
people in the English speaking World
they and them are by far the most common
pronouns for non-binary people but other
languages don't all have it quite so
easy around a third of the world's
languages use grammatical gender in
which nouns are typically sorted into
male and female or masculine and
feminine for example in French La the
table is feminine and in German D the
key is
masculine but languages with grammatical
gender pose a problem for those who
don't identify as male or female so they
are coming up with some innovative
solutions Spanish is one language where
activists have come up with a fairly
elegant solution the use of the ending a
on nouns and adjectives rather than the
usual o for masculine or a for
feminine and the pronoun aay has been
invented to be the equal equalent of
Spanish is they or them for non-binary
people because it closely resembles both
El for he and Aya for she and in Swedish
the pronoun hen is gaining ground as a
neat compromise in pronunciation between
Han for he and hon for she but some
languages are easier to tweak to
accommodate non-binary people than
others Mandarin has just one word for
both he and she which is
ta so far so good right
not exactly because in writing they have
different
characters some non-binary people have
begun using the Roman letter X joined
with the Chinese character or even the
Roman letters ta a but there's little
consensus and many people feel that
relying on the Roman alphabet is
suboptimal and unnatural and in other
countries non-binary people don't have
it so easy either French and German for
example like Spanish have grammatical
gender absolutely everywhere but they
don't have such easily available fixes
it may be some time before there are
elegant and usable Solutions everywhere
where non-binary people are seeking
greater grammatical
[Music]
visibility